فقط سهام دعيني هنا في هذا اليوم هذا
اليوم هو الحادي عشر من ايار هذا هو اليوم
الذكرى الاولى اغتيال الزميله شيرين ابو
عاقله نحن نتواجد هنا في موقع استشهاد
الزميله شيرين في وسط مدينه جنين على
مداخل المخيم زملاء شيرين من قناه الجزيره
قرروا ان يضعوا اكاليل من الزهور
ووضع نصب كتب عليه هنا انتصرت الكلمه على
الرصاص هنا اغتال الاحتلال نفسه بجسد
شيرين ابو عاقله بالطبع يعني رساله شيرين
كانت مواصله التغطيه والكثير من المراقبين
كانوا يقولون انه باغتيال شيرين اراد
الاحتلال اسكات صوت الصحفيين وعدم نقل
الحقيقه وعلى راسهم قناه الجزيره ولكن كما
نرى معكم سهام طواقم الجزيره منتشره في كل
المواقع حتى الصعبه منها الان في غزه على
الحدود وفي داخل اسرائيل هنا في الضفه
الغربيه اذا التغطيه مستمره لم تتوقف
نواصل معكم هذه التغطيه ليلا نهار ليبقى
صوت شيرين ساطعا والرساله التي ارادت
ايصالها صوت الحقيقه ان لم تستطيع ان تغير
الواقع بالطبع هي لحظات صعبه يعني راينا
منذ ساعات الصباح العديد العديد من وسائل
الاعلام صحفيين قرروا ان ياتوا الى هنا ان
يقوموا بتغطيه الاحداث الصعبه والعدوان
على غزه من هنا من امام مخيم جنين وتحديدا
من امام موقع اغتيال الزميله شيرين ابو
عاقله هنا في مدينه جنين قبل عام بالطبع
الجميع يفتقد شيرين في هذه التغطيه لهذه
الحرب على غزه ولكن بالطبع الاحداث يعني
وكثير ايضا هنا جاءوا وقالوا لانه لم
يحاسب احد على ق الزميله شيرين ابو عاقله
فواصل الاحتلال الاسرائيلي قتله
للفلسطينيين في كل يوم وفي كل مكان بالطبع
يعني منذ بدايه هذا الشهر فقط يعني 11
يوما فقط سهام سجل نادي الاسير 160 حاله
اعتقال استشهاد الاسير خضر عدنان في داخل
سجون الاحتلال الاسرائيلي اكثر من عمليه
اغتيال في نابلس وجنين وفي طولكرم وفي
قباطيه اذا الاحتلال الاسرائيلي يواصل هذه
العمليات العسكريه
والتخويف وترهيب الفلسطينيين ولكن كما
ترون الجميع يواصل العمل الليله نهار
وبالطبع اخر الشهداء هو شهيد هذا اليوم
حمامده ونقول حتى اللحظه لان كل فلسطيني
لم يعد يعرف في الساعه القادمه ماذا يمكن
ان يحدث نعم جيفارا بالفعل نفتقد شيرين في
الميدان والذكرى اليمه نحييها جميعا
الذكرى الاولى لاغتيال الشهيده شيرين ابو
عقله